hey youtubers is Charlie this Agreement
Walking Dead midseason finale video
lot of crazy things happen not in the
way that I expected them to though
so in addition to everything going
bananas we need to talk about what's
going to be happening next
as well as the big post credits scene is
really cool but they actually use a lot
of these things to disseminate a lot
information about the direction the
show's going
real quick reminder in the grand
tradition mid-season families
I'm doubling the giveaway so all you
have to do to enter that is be
subscriber leave a comment box below the
into the video
careful first post in the episode if you
haven't seen it yet but started with top
five moments
number five Rick runs down agents it
well
there is a certain satisfaction in
seeing sit well he did more time
on another show I'm sure the actor that
plays in real life is totally nyse:
but he is such a douchebag on-screen in
with all the rate that was going around
the hospital
you have to assume that he might have
been in on some that creepiness to
so good riddance to him I just love the
way they build the momentum with that
car chase
Rick is like when a Ridley Scott aliens
like he's right I have an Alien movie
chasing down Sigourney Weaver
only the elite family get to this time
here's the deal is that the way the
editor that just jumping back and forth
like you don't even see that it's him
you to see the knife slash the water got
to the flies by but the minute the car
pulled in that alleyway i jus I knew I
was like
there's no way he is not going to hit
him with a car he finished the job with
the gun
I would have rather seen and just do it
with the car I did I love the imagery in
this episode
between Rick revisiting his heritage as
an officer the law
and these other cops at the hospital in
the last episode he was actually giving
us the machine by
this episode he seemed a little bit more
reasonable i think is wanted to
demarcate the hospital
versus the survivors like the really
wanted us to not like the hospital
people
it would've been a survey to plead a
little more in the US Lee like metric a
little bit crazier
me the hospital people like slightly
less rebbe either way
sit well may you rest in peace you've
done your job in another show
now he can go Hill hyder somewhere else
I'm given nine to 10 I'd the TV shows up
on another drama
you get killed on that show too number
four Beth in dawn
verses re pants junior yes that's right
there's more them
so did anyone else see like this beard
on thing going on where like she was
trying to ship herself with Beth
bet this was not having any other did
she's like hey we are best friends
let's cheers and boos and let's kill
officer mcrae be together
her seriously how creepy are all the
policemen their I mean
they want them to seem unlikable to be
this way included all this rape story
like
he really wanted you to not like all
these people with accepted on
but they wanted her to be more on the
fence it to give bet the opportunity to
had a big win in family put someone down
the elevator shaft
I would rather bet push them both down
but then she would have had to explain
to the other police officers who came
running what happened
the racism really interesting things we
learned in bed in dawn scenes
dawn covered up bet killing the first
officer mcrae be
but she clean the jar up and the body so
she isn't all bad
but she's very clearly delusional but
she's not think that there's rescue
inside
all the things that word is meant to
humanize don's character I get to this
point she seems like super crazy issue
seems slightly less so after these
scenes with bed but they really wanted
you to think about Rick whenever you're
thinking about Don
like these were two-sided the same point
doesn't the same deal with Shane like a
long time ago
until she went crazy in a course just
like chain Don also went crazy
number three abraham's group comes back
to the church
as predicted abraham's group family met
back up with the survivors
not quite the way I expected but it just
means that they can all head to the next
place together
in I don't think they're going straight
to DC but I do think that's going to
come out
the map showed up at the end the episode
in the POS credit seen so clearly that
is the destination
but it may not be the next destination
it was a great way to come in till like
the way they just crashed into frame
literally
just because I who Abraham is in his
personality I wouldn't be surprised if
he wasn't trying to keep the walkers
from getting out but uses I'm the park
here
in just happened to run over all those
waters I would be so funny
he is so much fun when he's being like
dude Abraham crazy Abraham
is fun too but if you like you can only
have one really crazy person in the
group at a time
in rick is the crazy person right now
although given
given to the episode Darrell might be
the new crazy person
maybe even Maggie to actually know it
maggie is going to take the ground
Maggie will be the crazy person for the
next couple episodes
she's kinda crazy to begin with but in a
fun way number two
Morgenpost credit seen so what
information about Morgan in the scene
he is just behind the group not super
far behind
they didn't show is shot in the leg in
the grill but he was at the school like
me basically pollen
footsteps I like the little shrine that
he put out I felt like that was for his
son
accusing little prayer for his son and I
got was part of his ritual
but he wasn't gonna eat that candy with
the Matt tells us is
is that he was not openly following Rick
he didn't know they were still alive
but now that he does he probably will
help I end up in DC
some guessing that we might not see him
with the survivors to like the very end
a season 5
if not the beginning a season six but I
think that will happen we will get that
moment
I'm actually gonna hoping that before
the end of the second half to the season
we actually get like a Morgan episode
does Morgan in an entire episode but I
don't know that in their budget
but the really only do that for like the
most special characters like for the
governor before they killed him in
for Beth a sensibly before they kill her
maybe if we do get a more gonna be so
that means that you gonna die too
now it does really suck or maybe he's
going to be the Jesus character from the
comics
been to the given that storyline like
your shopping be a total badass
if people have read the comic to use put
tags if you want to talk about Jesus
and my number one WTF moment course bed
totally bite said so I'm all the people
that could have died in this episode
bed was at the top of the list with
Carol I could have taken it either way
I feel like the way the edited things
was a little confusing like they skipped
a couple moments
like your was just awake and lucid in
that wheelchair worship in coma toast
moments before
they didn't explain it too well bet
mustered just really jacked her up on
meds
where they must be keeping her under and
a lot of people are really happy to see
Beth go
but here's the thing that we need to
really talk about did bet stab her
knowing the dawn with shooter did bed
gonna commit suicide as a way to save no
one I will say yes
I think that she did on purpose she knew
that when she stabbed her with the
scissors
she would get shot let you die she's
like I get it now I get that I had to
get you to kill me so that no I can
leave
she talked about it earlier in the
episode everyone uses everyone else ok
bed learned that she had to use dont to
get what he wanted
and what she wanted was for know it to
be able to leave I think that's what you
meant when she said
I get it but let me know but would you
be a moment from the episode
and what do you think that bet meant
when she said I get it
in are you happy that she died that
thanks to the big question to you are
you happy the bed is gone and it wasn't
Carol
full disclosure I do feel like
carol is the more popular character
overall just in general I give the
finale
and a-minus not quite as good as the
midseason finale last year but
I didn't expect them to do the exact
same thing so I give them a high five
for not trying to completely repeated
the first thing that really comes to
mind in this episode aside from you know
someone really big dying is the way they
used the camera
first during rick's chase the beginning
the episode in and second
at the end of the episode with the Dutch
Engels that there was a crazy amount of
the jingles
for those who don't know that is when he
took the camera it is
adds dramatic tension to the scene if
you don't do too much if you too much
you get the more comical I felt like
they can draw the line at the almost a
little too much
it is wanted to imply that it was like
the classic gunslinger moment
but had sought to the cinematographers
on Walking Dead for shooting an amazing
chase scene
in an amazing standoff the show really
does work like a classic wild west story
I mean think about it but if you're in
the Wild West you can shoot someone
in not get arrested you kill someone did
not get arrested
too because there's been so much
speculation about bed in Carroll dying
you know her actually dying was now much
of a surprise so most to my attention
was on
the way they use the camera I wasn't
super connected with the best character
Emily Kinney I but did a pretty good job
for the way she went out but she did get
a couple really good here a moment
I feel like they didn't give her
character that much to do in the last
couple seasons so
you can't totally blame her if you
filter character wasn't that likable
as a couple critics talking about
something that they called Walking Dead
problem with women it had to do with the
female characters for the first couple
seasons
you know it'll be kinda figured Carol
out it she became the first
what is now like a group really bad ass
women but look at Sasha
Maggie Carol all them could pipe in for
themselves
like just as well as any the men on the
show it is really makes things but much
more interesting
when none of the characters are visibly
incredibly weak I mean everyone's gonna
breaking down inside
mostly everyones pry like a
five-year-old child carl's like the way
the reason now
which actually means he's pry next on
the hit list if that was you gain wisdom
on the show
like you're marked for death 15 wisdom I
get it now
damn she's dead should be like the
survival tip for walking dead
you want to survive just be dumb as much
as went down at the church in Philly
this episode belong to Rick
in bed
at in they were definitely on their
a-game I get the apps that have been
quite so uneven
I would have given it aside a theirs is
like no way they're going to be able to
match that prison battle from last
season though
if you give that in a vineyard to give
this like slightly less than that
so as make even a minus on to next
season though are the second half of the
season
very clearly third is hitting the road
like it is going to be
back after the season on the road going
from place to place although
there's a certain plays that supposedly
Robert Kirkman spoiled a long time ago
they're gonna change the names up it's
from the comics if you have read 'em
just please use but actually want to
talk about it I think they'll be at
least one big plays
before they get to Washington DC the end
I think that it's whether go
where that was going to take in any way
on all great episode but
usually doesn't get wat sup it is
basically a $20 on Amazon gift card but
because it's the finale and doubling its
own a giveaway to
Amazon gift cards member I have to do to
enter is be subscriber leave a comment
on as the winners mic unit tomorrow so
be sure to subscribe to everything
and I will be doing a top 10 moments
from the first half for the season
%uh do that in at least by Tuesday
probably this issue some really exciting
stuff happening on TV this week so
the clash a rogue crossover more walking
dead bones but he is coming so
and feel free to leave request to for
bonus videos for what he did is coming
back February 8
so is not gonna be gone that long in
case you haven't seen them yet have new
mobile Inc sapir
if you're watching on your mobile phone
is the same as the link that I had over
here
but you can click here for the Q Nadal
post tomorrow I'll be announcing the
winners then
and you can click here for my top 10
moments from the first happened this
season
oppose that in a couple days until then
I'll just a point to the Star Wars
trailer
but all I the link a little bit thank
you so much watching plots all high five
re what steps are be like 10 16 times